hey this is Vinny Testaverde and I am
here to build my squad now I'm gonna
pick my all-time football lineup okay my
first pick at quarterback is Tom Brady
well I think Tom has proven himself he's
one of the best if not the best to ever
do it put him in any situation any
weather playoffs roll whatever the
situation he can handle it running back
Jim Brown you can even ask the greatest
of the great running backs oh they'll
all tell you Jim Brown was the best to
ever play at his position wide receiver
have to go Randy Moss I would love to
have had for any of my team to throw do
so I'm gonna go with Deion Sanders
because he was the best at it and if you
ask the fastest of the fast they would
tell you that they would never want to
play against Deion because he can cover
everybody
and finally linebackers I'll go at Ray
Lewis because not only was he great but
he's a former teammate of mine and I
love Ray great player and if it wasn't
him it'd be Lawrence Taylor but there's
a lot of comparisons between the two but
Ray wins out because he was a teammate
locked in quarterback Tom Brady one of
the best to ever do it Jim Brown and
running back the best to ever do it we
got Randy Moss who nobody can guard at
any era Deion Sanders the fastest of
them all can cover anybody and finally
Ray Lewis I think I picked a good squad
so obviously I'm here for Super Bowl
this week and I've played my college
football in Miami it's great to be back
here and I'm here with Straight Talk
wireless which is a prepaid no-contract
wireless service and last year during
the Super Bowl fans streamed the event
across 7.5 million devices and we're
hoping that that's even more this year
and if you're looking to find out more
information about it you can go to
straight talk comm